Dyslexia: so what is it all about?
Well, dyslexia is a word that is used to describe a difficulty with written language,...
...organization, and short-term memory.
However, no one's dyslexia is the same.
Dyslexia is like a thumbprint,...
...every print being different.
Dyslexia is a difference in how the brain works.
This can have positive effects also.
Often, dyslexics are good at practical tasks,...
...whilst many are good communicators or problem solvers.
It is estimated that about ten percent of the population are dyslexic.
But being dyslexic does not affect intelligence.
In fact, there are many successful dyslexics in all walks of life.
Everybody finds certain things easier than others.
And we all have a talent.
It's just a case of finding what your particular talent is.
Most dyslexics find a word-based society extremely challenging.
Self-confidence can be dented if they constantly fail at school.
Dyslexics need to be taught in a way that matches the way they learn.
Low self-esteem often holds dyslexics back in life.
Difficulties with literacy or organizing yourself can cause problems at work, school or college.
It is important that a dyslexic gets the right support when it's needed...
...and plays to their strengths whenever possible.
Relationships with friends and family can be stressful if other people don't understand.
It really does help to talk so you can all understand how everybody is feeling.
Being dyslexic is for life.
There is no quick fix.
But with determination and support, happiness and success will come.